bleed or not comic-con isn't the only
thing going on this week the Republican
National Convention is also happening in
Cleveland yeah so there are a lot of
fans here in honor of both conventions
happening at the same time we thought it
would be fun to bring out someone who
represents both comic-con and the
Republican Party he's here tonight
please welcome captain make America
great again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks coded I've waited a very long
time to be here I have to tell you we're
all thrilled to have you captain make
America great again yeah agreed Koda now
listen
booking me is gonna be huge for America
which needs my super powers now more
than ever
okay I'm sorry what exactly are your
super powers
well I have all the best super powers go
tonight believe me I know
super powers okay I just didn't know you
had any super powers I'm not sure about
that look look look look this city needs
me all right I was walking around San
Diego today and frankly this place is a
dump I thank you it's overrun it's
overrun with rookies zombies and clay
guys yes yes so that's supposed to be
its comic-con well let me say this all
right that klieg our planet they're not
sending us their best all right
no it's true we're getting rapists
Klingon now we're not drug-dealing
Klingons oh and they all seem very very
angry and none of them speak English
that's that's it everything you just
said it's very offensive
Jodi code I am going to build a wall
between all the planets and I will make
the aliens paper that's not no just you
should go I think you should go your
views are not welcome here I will make
San Diego and America great again
[Music]
because I am the hero comic-con needs
and the one it deserves yeah
hail Hydra
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]